beaucoup de bruit ce mardi 24 ans tom
autour du siège social de sodexo a dû
ans pour une trentaine de salariés du
site de production de nouveaux est venue
protester contre la fermeture de leur
usine décision qui entraînera la
suppression de 62 postes d'ici la fin de
l'année
leur objectif aujourd'hui n'est plus de
sauver la structure mais de négocier au
mieux leur départ on va faire du bruit
non notre supra-légales surtout parce
que maintenant que quand on sera
licencié ben on voudrait fait d'avoir
quelque chose pour partir pour démarrer
et un nouveau à dreux sur sur la ville
de trou on n'a pas travaillé du tout
donc on voudrait partir avec un supra
légale
quand même à la hauteur de ce qu'on
mérite donc voilà on est là c'est pour
battre et on lâchera pas en parallèle de
la manifestation une réunion s'est tenue
dans le siège de l'entreprise à
guyancourt avec les partenaires sociaux
et la direction
le but trouver des solutions trois
alternatives ont été proposées par le
leader français de la restauration
collective
la première c'est pas de leur proposer
un poste chez sodexo et llodra il ya des
propositions qui ont été faites
concrètement pour pour des reclassements
on a une deuxième piste inquiets la
possibilité de voir le site être repris
par une société qui serait intéressé par
les locaux
on a des contacts très sérieux qui sont
en cours donc il ya cette perspective
et puis une troisième perspective qui
est l'accompagnement des collaborateurs
qui chuteraient mener un projet en
dehors de l'entreprise et pour lequel on
peut les accompagner dans la formation
dans les projets de reconversion
au total une quinzaine de postes
auraient été proposés par sodexo sur
d'autres sites une nouvelle réunion
pourrait être programmée la semaine
prochaine entre les parties si la
situation n'évolue pas les manifestants
ont déjà prévu de reconduire leur
mouvement dans les yvelines